hey
um
so you are the owner of this special or
so the boat broke down okay and I was
called and I brought the mechanic on
board okay the guy in the I don't know
if this is that one I think I saw one in
the blue shirt why because he wanted to
go home and I started taking my friends
in the dinghy and then he was just
really pissed off I don't know where he
started pulling out this weapon he said
I'm gonna shoot all you guys
yeah a handgun you know what type of
handgun a Glock or you have any
description silver black really pull
that out and pulls it out using the
black on the back um
okay
okay if we can have those three females
that are in the office
so he's advising uh
all right
just for the record um
do you want to press charges
is you
you're the victim
s
all right
you don't know who I am you know and the
girls are like oh no this guy has a lot
of money
did David tell you the people
tell you about books yeah yeah
foreign
for the deal
yes ma'am
oh yeah
okay
[Applause]
no one got your name or date of birth or
anything yet I could give you any okay
okay I'm gonna take it down real quick I
got that you got that Davido I might
have it on my phone a picture
my password is in my car right here okay
just give me your name
what's your first name Buddy Justin
you have a middle name Michael
Hensley
h-e-n-h-e-n-h-e-n-s-l-e-y okay what's
your date of birth Justin thirteen
seventy five
address
hang tight buddy thank you that's our
reason your license right how it reads
on your license yeah yeah okay
I think doesn't Michael him
um
that's why we ask people not to use the
phone
I know they probably ask you you
chartered to vote for a large amount of
people yeah well it was
okay okay
personal adjustment
s
it was like three people like 10 people
win I don't think he fit 10. do it back
and forth three times okay so what is
your culture I I turned it both so
you're a captain no okay no I've ridden
the boat have fun oh okay so you charted
the ball where did you find the bus
okay how much was it for today
how many people did you bring with it uh
however many girls are there and then
one male one male client named Joel and
the only one other guy here at home he
was the first shuttle to go
I let him go first there's a tiny little
thing
they said the boat was broke down and it
worked fine all right
should we get the complainer out there
verify paperwork of ownership
we're not going anywhere
foreign
oh
yeah
okay
what kind of refusing to move them both
so he was just like honestly like we
need to grab this boat there's people
here like we need to get off the boat
okay
but there's multiple people a gun came
out so that's why you know what I mean I
just want to appreciate like being
yelled at by Mr Gonzalez and talking to
me as if I'm gasping like I I think it's
I think I don't think he was directing
that towards you now he might have been
just looking at you
foreign
[Music]
location
to search your message 100 okay tear it
apart okay
you know this is
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
um
[Applause]
where are you guys at uh
[Music]
do you know of any other property that
this is Richard
but
sat there
all right
where's the upstairs
yeah I was up yesterday or no you know
his name I just got invited here
[Music]
thank you
so just be careful because
yeah there could be interferences
I'm just being honest with you okay
right here
all right
oh God
once again
was he uh consuming alcohol
um
foreign
never going
on again
[Music]
guitar
[Applause]
s
anymore
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
make sure everybody
like
104 industrial Nebraska
um
[Music]
[Applause]
that's okay
all right
um
[Laughter]
in Europe tomorrow